thank you Yasser we are with Sam
Shanklin author of very tense game
against Hans Neiman uh Sam in the
opening it felt like he dropped a
theoretical bomb with this move Queen to
C1 tell us a bit about that it certainly
doesn't bust on them so I prepared this
and for like several games including one
with Chris trick and one with nariana I
just never got to use it um but I think
that uh black is certainly fine but it's
not that easy to play his position like
for example um probably the most
accurate is to play H6 First bishop H4
and only now Bishop B7 so that I don't
have H4 but like this is tough and then
that's it's sort of and it's also a
little scary to play H6 when you know
that I could in theory play H4 and
response but
um there's probably other ways to
equalize but here like and we were
looking at trying to understand the
differences with this move C5 and E4 now
you take taken there's no more G5 there
okay Bishop F1 King F1 I believe E5 is
my move which is very tough to find I
think and even then where I can still
play but no I mean there's a there's a
very issue with Queen C2 instead of
Queen's Z1 and this one black is
definitely supposed to play H6
and Bishop H4 and then Knight speed D7
and now E4 comes in Queen C8 and
basically the point is here black is
fine because after Bishop A6 Queen A6 uh
Queen C6 already we're trying to screw
this up with White Queen D3 the big
point is that now after E5 because he's
managed to flick in H6 and Bishop H4
Knight D5 comes and I cannot take his
Knight I'll be mated and now I'm in
trouble between native four and I made
it so
um so basically the whole point with
Quincy one is to try to discourage H6 so
if black plays Knight bd7 I can just
play the same line honestly like yeah so
if it was like H6 now now after Knight
video seven this is the point is that
now the queen Navigator G4 G4 and now
this gets very I mean even here I think
black is probably fine but good luck
um so uh yeah I mean the way he played
it I don't know I mean Bishop B7 is
probably basically fine the way he
played uh H4 and now Knight C6 I mean I
I didn't have this move it looks really
bad and it doesn't like it's a slight
mistake at least yeah I mean I I know
there was he can take the pawn with
Bishop of three and queen D4 but it's
very scary
um C5 I think sort of equalizes after DC
Knight D7 C6 Rook C8 Knight D4 95 but
still a queen F4 I go Rook do like
there's some line here Rook C8 Knight D4
95 Queen F4 and computer calls this
equal after Knight C6 this much I knew
but okay take take Rook D1 I swing Rook
H3 around some point The Bishop's matter
I don't know
um but uh yeah yeah well I thought he
would take with the rock but anyhow it
doesn't matter um but the way he played
with uh with Knight C6 looked very
suspicious to me and I thought I should
just be better but I was struggling a
little bit to find the way I was very
surprised by Knight D5 actually as well
and I think the computer was saying H5
yeah but
just because after each things you can't
think of it yeah but if you take Sun for
I somehow didn't love my Pawn on H5 now
and
um yeah so H6 and it's not so easy for
me to coordinate I thought the Box
probably more time to take probably too
much that's that's way too much work I
see it and that F5 so yeah I don't know
I mean I thought Rook C1 felt natural
enough and the real question was if I
could do something better than what I
did I don't know I mean
yeah so this was coming and I wasn't so
sure yeah
um so uh yeah I thought I was a better
hero I wasn't sure how much but
um uh yeah so take take Knight D2 and I
was absolutely shocked by D5 I thought
this totally underestimated the danger
of the structure I mean I think he's
worse if he doesn't play this but
probably not that much worse than should
holds but here I actually thought I had
very good winning chances and I really
came very close to winning at the end I
think
um if we go forward uh yeah I didn't
know about playing B4 B5 I was worried
that he will go Bishop A4 and then
Knight C6 and
uh so any once he does that done enough
he's got A5 coming with actual counter
play which I didn't like so I thought I
should play B5 I understood this sort of
just on the queen side but the problem
was I just couldn't quite break through
there was a critical moment I think was
right on move 40.
um yeah so here I thought he's just in
huge trouble
um okay so yeah I don't know maybe this
is just a draw but so here take take
sure and I was expecting A6 after Bishop
C2 actually
A6 or A5 yeah well I thought S6 just be
very forcing okay BS ba6 and then
apparently it's just fine I think one of
the lines was yeah Bishop takes b57 yeah
try to go for the E6 Pawn Yeah uh but
it's not enough yeah so yeah uh yeah but
the way I thought it came very close to
winning so after I got Knight B1 Bishop
G8
A5 I think Bishop F7 was only move right
because if he plays Bishop H7 I believe
it's lost I gotta take take and then
Knight D2 or A6 yes yeah and this one
was winning I was really hoping for that
but he made the right decision to come
back to F7
and then A6
yeah and so here Knight A3 was good so
now I'm just curious if I can win this
position after Bishop D7 because my
understanding here is if I can put my
net on D4 I believe white wins okay then
like I'm the king I'm threatening Knight
C6 and I'm threatening King F4 and G5
and you cannot stop both of them and the
problem is that his Knight is terrible
on C5 but I was sort of thinking here I
don't actually see how I can get my
knight to E4 was the problem without
letting his Knight get free let's see
this computer issue Bishop yeah but the
problem is I need to defend the B5 Pawn
to get my knight to D4 and I didn't see
how to do this so so you tried to put
the bishop on this diagram yeah I think
if he doesn't play Knight E4 he probably
loses actually like I mean well okay
let's say like I don't know if he goes
Bishop E8 if he just wastes time Bishop
E2 Bishop D7 I suspect I should win this
if my knight gets to E4 but yes like so
we go now King E3 I think waiting one I
mean I guess you can always just go 94
but if you just yeah that move just says
Knight C2
and then King wherever F7 Knight D4 and
then yeah once I got the Knight to D4
it's winning so I guess but he has 94 in
time so I also could have tried Knight
C3 on move 39. instead of Knight A3
with the points that now I can it's
easier to go Bishop D1 D2 but the
problem is here after something like
King f8 and then Bishop D1 I think he
can still play Knight E4 here what's the
issue I think this is still just a draw
and I don't believe I will win yep
which was very frustrating yeah um but
uh yeah I thought I came very close but
I guess with a couple
I just couldn't quite get the
coordination in time at the end he
played very accurately now one thing uh
that you always feel very proud about is
your physical prowess and the fact that
you're working out and the fact that you
can maintain energy levels throughout
the long event this is a very long event
you feel that helps you well I guess
we'll see you in rounds 11 12 30. I
can't remember ever losing the last
round of the US Championship I don't
believe I've ever lost the final round
um but no I mean you know Fitness is not
wildly relevant until you've you know
started to play seven eight nine games
but you know I certainly hope it'll help
guys any uh extra questions just on that
note uh Sam uh Fitness what do you do
tennis basketball
one two uncoordinated for sports all my
teammates would hate me
um no I do a lot of weights I do
calisthenics I have a Peloton I like to
ride
um do a lot of like weighted pull-ups
weighted push-ups and try to also just
like I live in a very walkable area and
so just walking to everything grocery
store restaurants you just like average
four miles a day just by choosing to
walk even if you're not trying to
explicitly exercise it burns a lot of
calories keeps you fit I mean I'm not uh
you know the biggest Health Nutrition
Fitness Guru there's ever been but you
know I do things that work for me and uh
well I think it's helped so far fair
enough uh good luck in the tournament uh
Sam